police are on the scene of a deadly
crash near fort apache and warm springs
our other breaking story tonight streets
in that area are closed let's get right
out to madison kimbrough who is live at
the scene with more madison
yeah arby avenue continues to be closed
here in the canyon trails area
still very active scene here as you can
see this crash happened around 3 pm this
afternoon the person driving the car is
suspected of driving while drunk
according to police there were four
people in the car total three survived
with minor injuries edgar almonte who
lives in the neighborhood shares what he
saw as he was driving home i look at the
in the back of my rear mirror and i saw
a car spinning out of control it was
just spinning left and right left and
right it hit the wall from side to side
i decided to turn around and i actually
called 9-1-1 and i was the one you know
kind of like making sure that everybody
was okay in the car
but then we noticed that there was
somebody that got ejected out of the
vehicle
according to elmonte they were driving a
tesla and the driver who survived the
crash was taken in by police suspected
of a dui he also says it didn't look
like any of them were wearing their seat
belts while it's unknown how fast the
driver was going neighbors say speeding
and racing in this area is very common
there's even a vigil down the street of
a fatality that happened years ago as a
result of someone speeding keep it here
on 8 news now as we will bring you the
latest details all through the night
coming up at 11 p.m reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now